[inaudible]
delighted to be here today.
And thank you so much for coming.
It's a great audience.
And I hope I'll introduce you to a subject
that I've been interested in for most
of my adult life and have tried to
distill into this little book. Um, it's,
I've got a coauthor who was
actually a student of mine, uh,
Katy von [inaudible] who works in the u
s and so we tried to make sure that the
book wasn't just a UK based book.
She's bought in some ideas,
particularly she's also Dutch, so we've
got the European and the U S perspective.
Um, so she's, she's a, she works
in the, in the u s at the moment.
So I, I'm going to try and just
briefly introduce you to this area. Um,
it's, it's a, it's covers a
range of, of, of, of specialties,
but I'm going to tend to speak from my
own experience, which is inevitable. Uh,
I'm, I'm, um, I've,
I've worked as a clinical psychologist
originally training just to work in, in,
in clinical work.
But in later years I found myself being
more interested in research and then
eventually in teaching and training.
So my last post,
the last 20 years has been running the,
the doctoral training course in Oxford
to train new clinical psychologists.
And as such,
I had to have a kind of overview of the
whole subject and hopefully was then
therefore in a good position to write
this very short introduction as you know,
35,000 words. And I worked in
the air for about 40 years,
so we bought a thousand words per year
of my life went into this book and
therefore it's quite crumbed.
Um,
so what I'm going to try to do is really
talk to you about what it's about and
what we're trying to do
as clinical psychologists.
And I suppose the best place to start is
if you like what I often say to my own
family and to myself, which is,
it's actually tough being human.
Being a human being is difficult.
We haven't so many differences and
difficulties to deal with in our lives.
Complex feelings, emotions, desires,
challenges throughout life, managing
other people, managing ourselves,
managing the world around us.
So I've always been interested
in how do people do this,
how do people tick and what happens
when it goes wrong and have always been
difficult is in life.
We are not unique in finding life,
sometimes problematic.
If you've never experienced emotional
difficulties or relationship difficulties
in your life,
then you're incredibly lucky and I think
you'll probably quite rare sooner or
later in your life there are things which
go wrong and I'm not going to talk in
great depth about any individual case,
but later on in my talk I will talk
about a couple of examples of people I've
worked with. But it's tough managing
all the things you have to do,
your ambitions,
you need your family or parents
pressures and the world around you.
And that's always, I say always been the
case, not just now in in in the century,
but in many hours, centuries. We know that
there's the has always been different.
Not everybody finds it easy just to get
on happily in the world that they're
born into and they've always been ways
societies had to offer people somewhere
feeling better about
themselves and other people.
When people find things difficult,
and I've just listed historically arrange
of ways in which society has offered
people who are struggling a bit and
there are many ways of dealing with the
stress of [inaudible],
right? So start off as a law.
People who behave differently or
oddly we deal with them legally,
we put them in a class. Maybe that's
somebody who's got, who's behaving badly.
We put them in prison,
we put them away somewhere.
So the law deals with people and this to
this day when people start behave Bevin
strange in the street or something
happens, which is challenging,
we may call the police or
a lawyer to deal with that.
That's one way of dealing with
people who are behaving differently.
Another way of course is medicine and
medicine has always been a place nowadays
we tend to turn to if you are unhappy
currency or GP and maybe they can find
some way of helping you with that.
Other ways include religion and somewhere
that if you like you can go and see a
priest. And typically and historically
these three uh, three methods,
the law,
medicine and religion have been where the
people dealt with feeling low feeling,
having difficulties, children
behaving, her challenging,
behaving in ways which we want
to change those if you like.
Those are the big ways in the past,
people that dealt with difficulties.
I've also put magic there because again,
another approach is for example,
using astrology or some other sort of
technique to deal with people who are
behaving strange or feel
bad about themselves.
And to this day you could look up in
[inaudible] astronomical science and look
up what,
what read the future.
People still use us the way of making
themselves feel better when they're not
happy.
I mentioned politics there again cause
such changing society is another way of
trying to change people's emotions and,
and,
and ability to get on with life if like
those have been the big ways in which in
the past we've dealt with distress but
increasingly and certainly since the 19th
century, people try to
understand the mind to Perth,
try to understand what's going on inside
our heads and the science of psychology
has developed. And that's the
background to clinical psychology.
And I will just briefly mention
what that is and if you, um,
psychology is now the most in demand
undergraduate course in the UK to do your,
to do your degree in and it's the most
competitive one most competitive degrees
to do. And it's a site, it's a study
of human experience and behavior.
And very quickly I've run through
some of the things that happens within
psychology in order to become
a clinical psychologist.
You studied this first and the kind
of things we'd study is how is it,
we learn things, how we, our memory works
and importantly how we forget things.
That's very important part of the system.
What stress does to us and how we
are different from other species,
how hormones operate on us and how,
for example,
drunks called work on the body
and the mind, why do we sleep,
why don't we sleep? Um, and what it
is, how the perceptual system works,
how the brain sees
fields and our emotions,
work perception, how
perception works, how we are,
how we recognize people and
how we attend to other people,
to anything else and
how we make judgments.
So the whole way in which the brain
works is the subject of psychology.
And as a science, it's really quite
recent, maybe two, 200 years or so.
But the most progress has been
made within the last 50 years.
Other things psychology does
is why we have emotions,
what we feel and particularly child
development, how children learn, how to,
how they learn social behavior
and language and how people
attach to one another.
Now important relationships
are how children's separate,
when they eventually do what
that process is more important,
important it is and what the effects
of aging are. How we get along,
how we behave differently
socially with other people.
And how groups differ from one
another and why we get on without the,
how we get along with authority.
There's just a sampling of what you
study in psychology. So that incentive,
you might have done a psychology degree.
This will be familiar to you and this
is the equivalent as in medicine.
I studied genetics, physiology, anatomy.
So if you want to be a
clinical psychologist,
you do all this first so you have a
notion of how the human mind works and how
people behave.
So that's our bread and butter.
So that if likes a degree
that I originally studied,
but I was most interested in what
would it all goes wrong when people are
unhappy and what happens during the
periods of life for most of us have some
challenges.
What can we learn in the same way as
when you do anatomy and physiology and
genetics if you're a doctor,
if you're on some that, when,
what is it when it doesn't work? So
clinical psychology, which is the same.
My interest is the application
of psychology in clinical
settings where people
have emotional,
own psychological difficulties and these
include hospitals in particular mental
health and but also child health and
also or clinics where the people present
with psychological distress.
So clinical psychologists work
in a variety of different places.
My early years in the 1970s eighties
was working in psychiatric hospitals,
but people also work in general hospitals,
so works across the lifespan from infants.
So how people may have difficulties in
early relationship attachments and things
like adoption and some of the kinds of
difficulties that children can experience
and the relationships when early bird
were between parents and babies through to
the very old and the 12 process of
letting go of life at the end of life.
Now we will,
as clinical cycles,
you work very closely with medicine and
I mentioned the training to become a
doctor. One of the things you can
do, I mean, I, if you know all this,
forgive me if I'm telling you stuff
you know, but just in case, um,
one of the specialties within medicine
when you've done your basic training,
you can choose to do with psychiatry.
Now psychiatry is different from
clinical psychology in that to be a
psychiatrist, which in fact our daughter
is, you have to do medicine first.
So she's done the whole business of
anatomy, physiology and all that stuff,
which I didn't do.
So she's very familiar
with and psychiatrists know
about how the body works and
their treatment of mental health
problems tends to be oriented towards the
physical.
So for example,
the treatments psychiatrists tend to give
if you say so if you're suffering from
depression or stress and you go see
a psychiatrist, they will tend to,
first of all,
they'll do a very thorough
physical examination and
they will may well give you
some medical treatments,
some of the antidepressants or some
other sort of physical treatment for your
condition. Now, I'm not
qualified to do that. I'm not
a doctor. I wouldn't do that.
But I work very closely with doctors so
that we will see people where perhaps
medical treatment isn't appropriate
or it's not thought to be helpful.
In this case where we have
a close relationship, we
cross refer to one another,
but we have a different treatment.
Our trip is psychological,
not physical though I'm very aware.
Of course we have bodies and therefore
Homans and things are important and and
and drugs do have an impact in deed.
There's nothing wrong with,
with psychiatric treatments
like like antidepressants,
they can be used very much
with psychological treatments.
So we worked together,
so particularly psychiatry and
we offer different perspectives.
So by and large the model and
lung psychiatry underlying
it is a physical one,
which is something wrong with your hormone
balance or with the endocrines or the
the brain chemicals. So you can fix
it with a match with medication.
Whereas will understand when people have
distress, depression or personality,
relationship difficulties or children
behave challenging ways or families
breakdown. There isn't an illness.
It's happened to you though.
That's convenient label.
It's not an illness.
It's a complex human response to
trauma or challenge or difficulties.
So what's wrong with you is while we
can treat it medically and often those
treatments help.
Interestingly they do help.
The cause may be something else.
So by and large what we do is help people
to develop solutions to their problems
rather than if it come and find a
medical way of fixing it. But again,
we do work with doctors and
if you do have depression,
often the very first useful thing to do
is to try antidepressants cause we know
they are effective and
if they're effective,
fine cause you can get back to work and
that's great but if it doesn't fix it or
you don't want to use antidepressants,
often a psychological approaches,
that is the next step.
To complicate matters,
many psychiatrists also used
psychological treatments. Uh,
so they will use the methods I might use
but I won't be prescribing because that
isn't my background. So we do work
with them, but our specialties,
the psychological,
based on all that research,
all that knowledge do with how
people think, how people perceive,
how people develop,
all that stuff I mentioned earlier,
which is our kind of basic stuff.
So we work with people trying to develop
a solution to the problem and based
very much on the
collaborative relationship.
So patients are referred to clinical
psychologists usually because they go to
see their GP or somebody
suggests they may be,
they need a bit of help perhaps cause
that they've got difficulties in the
family.
The child is repeatedly challenging or
difficult or the child's very anxious or
perhaps the adult you will me.
And it's very much like all of us
could be in a situation, feel, uh,
feel depressed or anxious,
have difficulties in our relationships
or maybe granny is getting more and more
challenging to us living at home with us.
We didn't quite know how best to help the
family to adopt the fact we've now got
granny living with us. And
that's difficult with also
got a teenager who, who,
who wants to go out drinking
and all sorts of problems.
There's a human problems
which aren't illnesses. Can
we find a way of solving it?
And we very much work with people who
bring their problems to us and tell us
about the main conference
because it's confidential. And,
um,W and collaborative we is,
ethics is very important to us.
So we have a very strong ethical code.
We are regulated by the Health
Professions Council, uh,
which is like the General Medical
Council. And we also have, um,
a professionalization of the
British psychological society,
which has codes of ethics
that we have to abide by.
And these specify very clearly we're
there to help the patient, not ourselves.
And that's important because typically
what happens is that a patient will come
see me,
see me and I should mention I've mostly
worked with adults will come see me with
a problem or difficulty and will trust
me hopefully with telling me some very
intimate personal things.
And My responsibility is to help them
the best I can solve their problems.
Not to like not because I think I've
got the answer. Uh, I can't say, oh,
well if you voted labor,
your problems will be solved.
That wouldn't be my responsibility.
Um,
I've got to help them
work out the solution.
And if you like this little
cartoon summarizes it, um,
we're encouraging people to become
involved in their own rescue. Uh,
I don't think that's very ethical there.
There that might is busy reading his
comic, but one of the persons drowning,
we wouldn't quite do that.
We certainly don't come up with answers
for people because there isn't any point
in that we don't have an answer.
We help people to think differently and
to help them to see how they got into
the flight,
into the situation they're in when
they're feeling muddled or they're feeling
upset. So it's a color where our help,
I feel like we work with them to,
to,
to change the situation.
So the kind of people are
going to see clinical cycles.
You see the typical clients,
peoples with phobias or fears which
are very common or anxiety. Um,
these are the in ways some of
the easiest problems to solve.
If you've got a fear of,
of lifts or Wasps or spiders or
cliffs or something, airplanes,
there is quite relatively straightforward
difficulties and often that's to do
with people over longterm,
avoiding,
discovering those things are actually
quite harmless. So that's, that's a,
that's a very common difficulty.
Very common monks, children,
people often grow out of them.
But against people and get stuck.
People with depression,
that's more complicated problem and the
lots of reasons why you might experience
depression. Life is challenging for you.
We can't solve that. Life is difficult.
Life is tough.
Remember I said we can maybe help you
to understand the ways you've tried to
solve your depression are
paradoxically not helping you. Um,
so things like relationship problems,
people who've got against stuck
in things which are difficult,
needs another perspective. People
with eating disorders and psychosis,
psychosis if um, is a, if you like how
we tend to use the term now, Robin,
schizophrenia or manic,
manic depression,
those are words we tend not to use so
much now because we're much more thinking
about what's going on in the mind.
Psychosis is disordered thinking.
We're starting to understand it
better now. Um, based on lots of good,
very good psychological research,
but very serious mental health problems,
which are very challenging and
very disruptive to people's lives.
People who have long term difficulties
in the past used to be hospitalized,
but now we have better ways of managing
it together with psychiatrists who have
better drugs to help. Also people
physical illnesses like cancer,
stroke or spinal injury.
If you have a life threatening illness,
it affects the way you think and feel
inevitably and children with a range of
family and individual. Um, uh,
disorders of different types. Um,
difficulty in relationships,
school refusals,
disruptive behavior in the family or
child anxiety, which is very common.
And people with brain injuries
and developmental disorders,
all of which have a psychological
component. You can't just have,
say diabetes or stroke or heart disease
without it also affecting how you think
and feel.
So we use a number of models.
Some of you have heard a
CBT that's very common.
Now the cognitive model says the thing
that's let's pay attention to when
there's a disorder on happiest.
It's how you think.
So we think we look at how
it is your understanding,
your perceptions of what's going on.
Um,
the underlying idea here is that sometimes
people can understand something in a
particular way,
which leads them to a particular emotions.
And what's difficult is the way they're
thinking when you are depressed.
For example, we know when
people suffer from depression,
they tend to think in more concrete ways.
They jump conclusions,
they'll see things in
more black and white,
which can lead you to make
assumptions about the world. Um,
and I'll come back to them in a
in, in a minute, but that can lead,
that can aggravate your low mood.
So when we're walking with working with
depression using a cognitive model,
we try to help,
help,
help people to see how their thinking
is actually unhelpful to them.
Behavioral people. We'd use
treatments, for example,
say with children whereby people,
we help people to train how they behave.
And again,
that leads to different consequences.
CBT is a combination of
behaviorism and therapy,
which is increasingly popular. A lot of
evidence suggests it's very effective.
Psychodynamic,
this is more fraudulent thinking.
Try to understand relationships
in particular attachments,
difficult difficulties. People have the
attachments or what I call systemic.
This is trying to [inaudible] system
around you perhaps at work or in your
family is aggravating or difficulties.
So we'll use all these models.
The way we work is,
is I feel like a series of stages.
First of all the person has assessed.
So a person seeing me,
I lost them about what's happening to
their lives. Uh, what's happened to them,
what, what, what's the history of the
problem? What's going on in your life,
who's in your family, are you working,
what else is happening to you?
So we might use questionnaires
or just talking to somebody.
We might pay attention to how
they are in relationship with us.
So our a very challenging or they very
passive to a pay attention to those
things in if like in the room,
in the assessment room will then come up
with a formulation which is a bit like
the diagnosis in medicine and
in particularly interested
in the predisposing
factors. What, what, what,
why does this person have this problem
here and what is something in the
background, perhaps they come
from a background where people,
branches and the family.
What precipitated,
what happened last week or a month ago
that led to it happening now and what is
the presenting problem? What's going on,
why is it staying there? Why is it purple?
Why is it perpetuated?
Why haven't people,
people don't want to be sick or
ill unhappy? Why is it going on?
What's what's going on? Why is it
perpetuating? And if you'd like,
what is going on?
We should protect in them in their lives.
Everybody has some good things.
So have they got good relationships?
Have they got good job?
Have they got something somewhere,
which is also helping them to manage.
So we need to know all of that.
We then come up with a formulation,
which is a trial,
which is like a diagnosis and I'll
show you some formulations in a minute.
We then do w in agreement.
We'll draw up a plan to intervene
to change things. For example,
if we use a cognitive model,
we might say we might set about a
series of cognitive experiments,
helping them to think differently about
what of the problem is or behavior.
We will, again, we may set
up against mental experiments
to do with the person. Uh,
there's just an example. Someone who's
frightened of going up and down and lifts.
They're frightened or some
catastrophic will happen.
Very scared to go near left you,
uplevel let's,
you'd have to walk up and down
the stairs every day, be a pain.
So what we will do is help the person
who's very frightened. This first of all,
watch me going up, trusting me.
I'll go up and down and lift that,
watch me doing it.
Then eventually we'll stand inside the
left without closing the doors and I'll
get used to that.
Next time we'll go inside.
Perhaps they'll go up together on
one floor, which is very scary,
but I'll be with them,
helping them to relax,
helping them to experience less tension.
And then the next time we might get them
to go up three floors and finally it
got on their own, up and
down. So that would be very
simple. Behavioral treatment.
If it's relationship problem, it's
not quite as simple as that. Um,
as you can imagine. But we would
come up with some other ways of,
of suggesting an alternative within
evaluate. Did it work? Didn't it work?
If it didn't work, go back to
square one, try something else.
At the same time we're doing with search
because we want to make sure we have
the right treatments for the future.
How we tend to turn work will,
it takes about eight years to train,
see somebody.
So I said to go in psychology first,
then we don't like to take
somebody straight off because
they're very young and
a little bit exit experienced when you're
21 so we often ask them to come and
get some work in the workplace.
May Be in hospitals or somewhere where
they're working with people and make sure
that they get bit more experience.
We then do a three year doctorate,
so that's why it's around
eight years altogether,
which is what my last job is
doing that to train people.
Our model is want landline is science
practitioner and I was, you're practicing,
we're not in labs but we are using notion
of science because we test something.
Does it work? Doesn't it work? If it
doesn't work, we try something else.
We're always measuring has it worked?
What's the outcome?
We get people to fill in,
questionnaires, drive them mad,
but we need to do that to make
sure we are on the right lines.
And we use research based evidence trials
which indicate what's what works and
what doesn't.
A lot of a role for that.
We spend a long time reflecting,
we need to make sure we're
behaving ethically and we're
aware of the context of
what's what people want to
do in one context with them.
With one ethnic grouping might be
different for another one. In the UK,
this is pretty much based in
the NHS. We've, we're fun,
we're trending is funded in the
NHS in the rest of the world.
It's very different people,
very much self fund the training and
work privately as a little bit of private
work in the UK increasingly.
But I've never worked private myself.
I spent all my life in the
NHS or in academia. Um,
if you want to see a
clinical psychologist,
they do advertise them
increasingly working privately. Um,
we normally it's people referred
by GP or another medical specialty.
So for example,
a renal specialist might say,
this person is having difficulties
adapting to the needs on dialysis.
Can you help them?
Or this person's had a brain injury,
let's work with them with a farmers
to help them back to normal life.
And it's typically based on a series
of sessions over several months.
So as the course of treatment
might be six months or whatever,
or less depending on what the problem is.
So I'll come up with the calendar and,
and I'm just going to show you a
formulation. This is a bit tricky,
but we often don't diagrams. So I want
you to have a look at this person here.
The very bottom, this diagram,
if you can see this person,
and this is a case taken from an from
book by Royale and courage as mentioned in
the book at the very bottom, this person
came to see it. She's a woman. She came,
her name was Beatrice.
It comes to see the psychiatrist or
psychologist feeling really depressed.
She describes us as being like a frozen
chicken in the supermarket. She says,
she's like wrapped up in cling
film as a frozen chicken.
That's a self image of herself frozen.
No longer in relationships,
aren't able to do anything really
miserable in early thirties that's how she
comes along. What do I do? Well,
antidepressants might help a bit,
but actually something else going on.
So we try to understand the story the
right back to the beginning of a story
inside the red box.
We've,
it turns out she has parents who
really were quite critical of her.
They were rejected her and were quite
demanding of her and she felt in response
to a parish,
she felt very guilty about it.
But she also tried to work really hard.
So she's in the red box there.
She's striving and needy.
Her needs aren't being met by a parent.
She's quite independent.
She's also quite rebellious school.
So there she's at school as a young girl,
she actually gets expelled.
So if you look on the side that rebel
gets rejected and you see that she has,
she gets expelled from school,
which just makes it feel worse.
So she longs for closeness cause she's a,
she's a, she's a attractive young woman,
makes us his relationships. He often has
relationships. She feels abandonment.
She's in the center now.
She feels abandoned.
She avoids getting close to
her boyfriends. She feels
very lonely. She withdraws,
draw people and needs are of an unmet.
She feels depressed and she
feels like a frozen chicken.
She doesn't dare reveal herself.
So she sometimes on the other side on the
left with left or right this side here,
she risks becoming closer to people.
He tends to idealize the
person she falls in love with.
She makes them out to be perfect, has an
eye, a moment of complete being in love.
They're perfect relationship.
She then feels totally, uh, she,
she feels been worthwhile,
but she feels being a gardener,
she run runs away again.
She can't cope with the idea of being
abandoned and she's back to the frozen
chicken sometimes on the other side
he strives very hard to please people.
She pretends to be something he isn't.
She hates herself. Her needs are unmet.
She doesn't reveal itself.
And then she feels depressed.
So if like this is a joint
collaborative formulation,
we've made it the kind of problems
that she has. That's a formulation.
Another example formulation here,
this was a man called Terri
who is to drink too much.
He had very can inside the red box
red circle. He had very rejecting,
abandoning parents who
are very contemporary,
sort of him as a child is in a place of B.
He's very lone,
felt his needs for closeness,
wanting was very, was contemptible.
And what we find in live as you,
you often tend to reproduce
psychologically some of
the things your parents did
to you in your judgments.
So he to himself was very rejecting.
He were angry with himself. What he
tends to do again, have, uh, he would,
he would, he, he was easy. He
worked, he worked in the industry.
What you would find is that one,
because he was quite contemptuous
and angry with people,
he looked around his peers.
They often find that other people weren't
as good as him. So they're always,
he would say to other people,
other people were, he's the,
he's the best of the people will be
better than him and he will do reject all
the people. Not surprisingly,
when he did that,
as we will reject him and he will
be then end up being very lonely.
And in fact,
what he ended up doing was drinking.
So he would end up being very depressed.
You turn, he was on the worst person,
the world and the drink.
So He'd have a pattern of being
contemptuous of others and contemptuous of
himself. And he will reduce that.
He would reproduce a pattern.
When we analyze his
relationships with others,
he would constantly feel he was
either the best or the worst.
He had one way of thinking about people.
He had to be the best of something.
Or the worst is something.
He was always winning awards at work.
And then he'd win awards.
He get, he'd have, he'd,
he'd boasts and other people would
then reject him and they didn't end up
drinking. Um, and it was a pattern.
He went round and round and round and
you'd find it very difficult to accept
himself as he was.
So that's the kind of formulation we
might draw up in collaboration with a
patient. And then following
a formulation like that,
we would then introduce ways of change.
So for example,
if you look at this lady here,
we then talked about her sense of being
rejected by others. Why, what, what,
what was about her, which
was, which wasn't worthy,
why she was avoiding closeness and try
to help her to accept herself more and
gradually therefore to stop
idealizing demand. She met,
we should go into a completely over the
top relationship where she'd want to
move in the day she met them.
And they will then run away from
a helper to be a little more,
more careful about the relationships
he got into and gradually develop
relationships where she could be with
people not as perfect without them being
perfect,
but more egalitarian relationship.
And again with Terri to help him to not
be so contemptuous of others because the
partner got into was always
to push other people to have,
which meant they put him down. So that's
what you might do in your, in your,
in your, in your treatment. So I say the,
that's quite a different approach
from giving someone antidepressants.
So we might well work with antidepressants
as say if somebody is filling
depression, depression, what
the challenges are is how
scientific is all of us.
You may say,
well what Scott got to do with science,
we try to be sounds practitioners will,
it's based on studies which
you've used models like this to,
they worked and they work. And so a lot
of evidence the CBT is effective as,
as I mentioned. Uh, and so when there's a
loss of, of have worked on what are the,
what are the,
what are the studies,
what does this treatment work just
well with which patients does it work?
And one of the problems we have in
psychiatry and psychology is that actually
humans are terribly, very, everybody
in this room has a different story.
Doing psychological research is
complicated because you all have different
experiences.
Whereas probably most of your kidneys
or livers work kind of the same mama the
mansion. But your history is your
psychology is going to be so different.
And we've tended to give one treatment
to everybody and what the research
demands is that we have more and more
nuanced treatments for different people.
You wouldn't want the same treatment as
the person next to you cause your life
story is different.
And that's why often we don't get it
right cause it's very typical to get it
right. Um, laws, medicine if like,
I like to say that there are difficult
subjects are probably simply because
people are not so different.
I mean there are many ways in which you
can be physically ill and break the law
and do have legal complications.
But if you like the numbers of ways in
which people relate to each other is
infinitely complicated. It's difficult.
And we do our best to be scientific,
but we don't always get it right.
Uh,
therefore we do spend a lot
of time thinking about it
and sometimes we get over
reflective and we spend our time thinking
and maybe that's not always helpful.
There are not so many of us because it's
very expensive to train somebody to, to,
to, to, to become a clinical psychologist,
several hundreds of thousands.
And so the stuff you like the NHS can't
afford that many and we tend to be
relatively few of us. So I don't know
how many of you ever actually had,
just out of interest,
how many few have heard of clinical
psychologists as a professional high?
You've heard of us? Great. But I,
I, but, but, but probably not many.
How many you actually no
clinical psychologists
personally, but for five years.
Okay. And that's, that's great that you
do. Um, there are not many. It's a many,
many more psychiatrists. I can't
trust some much more numerous than us.
And of course, many, many, many, many
more doctors. Um, there are many not more.
Most mental health care, certainly in
the UK is provided through the NHS.
It's provided by nurses and
doctors were very swollen number.
And so how can we have these
models are very interesting,
but it's hard to,
to actually see somebody,
the chances of seeing a
clinical psychologist are
really quite small because
there was so few of us.
Um,
and one of the other things is
that we know very well that the,
the things that often precipitate the
background to mental health problems in
particular are things like
poverty and, um, and, and, and,
and exclusion.
So we know that mental health problems
are much more dominant within groups that
have poor resources. Um, and if you like,
if you want to improve the mental
health of the nation as a whole,
you might want to pay more attention
to things like education and, and,
and employment, unemployment
and so on, uh, and inequalities.
Um, and we are looking, we are looking
at the individual victims, if you like,
we get the people who have been
damaged by some of those things. Um,
and maybe a better thing
would be to change society
as a whole because those are
the things that lead to some of the
mental health problems that there are. Um,
we're, we're fixing the individuals.
I appreciate you have to do both.
But often there's a tension
between should we treat the people,
should we try and change the system, which
leads to people having these problems.
We can talk more about that.
And so I'm,
one of the other things is could we
make you make much more better use of
individual and information technology,
the treatments,
purely CBT treatments that,
that um, are increasingly used.
There are open to being used
with technology. For example,
some of the individual treatments
around coming to see me to do a,
a desensitization, which is a treatment
for your fear of lifts or something.
Could you do that online? And there are
treatments which can be provided online.
I had a go at this myself actually a few
years ago because there's a very good
program for people who have
sleep problems called um, calm,
sleepy. Thank you. Cool. Sleepier
which is an a CBT online treatment. Um,
it's right in fact set up by a colleague
of mine from Glasgow University.
Now in Oxford. I don't have a major
sleep problem, but I thought, well,
I quite fancy you though. Sleeping a bit
better. So I did the sleep program, um,
which meant I had to go every week.
I had to go online and about an hour and
ask questions and do things differently
and it was very well designed and
actually I have to say really did work.
It increased my ability to sleep well
through the night and it was very nice.
Then tribals I kind of stepped back
into my bad habits after a while,
which is reading in the middle
of the night things and, and,
and stuff and stay in bed light,
which you shouldn't do if you've
got sleep problems. But um, yeah,
we should use information technology
better to try and spread if you like
psychological treatments to more people
and there are ways of doing that. Um,
it's very much what, what I think next
generation is going to include. Um,
so I think that that starts the next,
I've been sharing his here,
I'm macdougal thinking with you,
thinking about what can we do to
spread good mental health practice.
We know that depression is a
major cause of dysfunction in,
in the world out there.
Most of us in our lifetime,
we'll have either ourselves or one of
our friends and family will have some
mental health problem and it will cause
distress to farmers and we can treat it
medically,
although not everybody responds to
medication and in many ways having what we
know is that psychological treatment
and medical treatment together as one of
the best, but it's hugely time consuming
and it's demanding and it's expensive,
so it's somewhere in which we could
deliver better treatment better.
One of the things that makes it difficult
is that one of the things we know is
important in making a psychological
treatment work is relationship that you
develop with the person who were helping.
So that's very important that
we have a close relationship.
How can you reproduce a
relationship with a computer?
Because we know that that bombed the
person who goes up and down the lift with
me.
The reason she's prepared to do it is
we spent several hours beforehand where
I've listened to her, I've given
her my tension, she trusts me,
she knows that I respect her and not
belittling her and I'm therefore so she
trusts me in order to try doing it.
How could you do that if you like on a
computer? So that's one of our challenges.
How to deliver more widely the mental
health struggles that we have to people.
I think I've probably talked enough.
I was off talk about the two mature I've
done so I'm be more than happy to take
the conversation further in any
direction and people will be interested.
Some real patterns on the trunk.
It's an educational psychologist,
same as a clinical psychologist,
but thank you for asthma and I probably
should have clarified when you turn your
first degree, as I mentioned, all that,
those subjects you either you can just,
that's the degree. It could have
been history or physics or something.
Go and work for Google or something that
uses psychology again or you can come
at applied psychologists and they're
about seven branches of psychology,
which are applied. One is clinical.
That was a bit I wanted to do.
One is you mentioned educational.
There are things like occupational,
which is helping design
workplaces and things. Um,
educational is particularly
working with children in schools,
how children learn and uh,
looking in particular at
family difficulties so that
if you are interested in,
in how to be affect how dyslexia
and how children behave in schools.
That's narrowed to go into.
Whereas what I trained,
where I trained with lot within the NHS
in clinical settings, hospitals, settings,
um, education psychologist. So,
so I often do teaching first.
So they're very familiar with the
education system before they start working
with teachers about how to work.
Cause I worked in hospital,
I worked in the NHS as a, an assistant
occupational therapist for a bit.
So I got used to feel like
how the hospitals work,
how the doctors had teams work.
So you know,
the workplace actually psychologists would
use many of the same models like CBT.
So our theory is that the same,
it's the workplace. It is different.
But thanks for that question.
And it was
um,
I wanted to ask about widespread models,
I guess in my wife's per processes
because of course depression, anxiety,
they come from things such as maybe,
oh,
they stem from skills like
resilience and things like that.
Do you know if they're doing such,
you know,
what resilience course at schools
nowadays? It's interesting. Yes.
Because indeed w I think
very important contracts.
Although when you experienced depression,
anxiety, you think it's you because you,
you know, obviously that's
how you experience it. It
is indeed your, your life,
which is yeah,
which is in disorder or discomfort,
but you're not alone
and many other people,
same issues and things like stress and
the demands are commuting and the demands
of managing workplace and the family
and all that stuff as all this ads.
And you're, yes, the context is important.
So could we do something about that
context to reduce some of that stuff?
And because the real world in which we
are all competing and the demands is
difficult to change all of that.
And as we all go and give
up live in the countryside.
But assuming we don't do that
kind of workplace, do something,
can schools do something? One of the,
one of the, the kind of fashionable, um,
ideas is mindfulness. What mindfulness
is a way people have heard of that.
It's a way of trying to help you to get
away from particular critical thoughts
and the underlying model
why mindfulness works.
And they are teaching this in schools
now and maybe in workplaces it's like
relaxation. It's helping you to
get off the tray, the treadmill.
So if you look at the, um, I feel
like, uh, this, this poor person here,
she was in a treadmill because
people don't want to be unhappy.
We sometimes all she, she's her own
worst enemy. She makes it, she wants to,
she doesn't want to get better. It's
not that you don't want to get better,
you don't know how to change. So change
is very scary because if you always do,
if you always walk in the same way,
someone asked you to walk differently,
how do you do that? It's really hard
and we shouldn't underestimate that.
So what mindfulness on these trainings
try to do is to help you to get off the
treadmill that you're on and think or
think about it differently. So yes,
there is an attempt to do that and then
that is going to be a better way of
solving problems.
But it's such a huge thing and it's what
we know is that mindfulness does work
to a degree,
but then again it's not good enough yet.
We still don't have a panacea.
Okay.
Again, the evidence, the
evidence shows that it has a,
some small effect.
I can't,
they evidence on teaching mindfulness
in schools is for some children it is
helpful but not for all of them policies,
difficult to engage all the kids in it.
Um, so yes, the evidence is
that it wasn't, again, using,
trying to be scientist about it works.
Some people some of the time and we're,
we're on the case,
but with,
there isn't a solution to everything
yet cause it's cause it's complex.
So I know that's not a good story to
tell. I'd love to say yes, but it's not,
we don't know yet.
Somebody here had something.
Hmm.
Thank you.
I was wondering,
how do clinical psychology practitioners
deal with all the kind of the heavy
information and the whole kind
of difficult stories after work?
How they decompress?
I deal with it.
I think it's very interesting and
increasingly we're getting a bit better at
that than we were. Um, I, I mentioned
one of our skills as being reflective.
How reflective should we be?
Everybody in practice is
supposed to have a supervisor,
which doesn't mean someone
to tell you what to do.
It's somebody you can go and
talk to about things. Um, and I,
it is in a sense, it's like,
like being a doctor, you,
you kind of get used to it. And I, I, I
have to say that, that, uh, of my life,
I think I've become a bit inured
to stories that people tell me.
And sometimes I think I'm getting hard
hearted because there isn't too much
horrible stuff I have not heard of.
You do get used to it.
The thing that I find quite difficult,
so when I was first working,
one of the big issues are
talked about trauma. Um,
one of the things we know for example
is that childhood abuse and neglect and
abandonment as a child is,
is bad for you.
We know that having an unhappy
childhood is not good for you.
That's the one statement I can make.
Um,
and when you hear stories about how
children have been harmed by society or by
families, that's very difficult. I used
to find that really hard to hear that.
Absolutely.
We don't have my own children.
I was hearing stories about children
and abuse. That was difficult. We do,
we do have the audio is you have somebody
who's been through it before and I
think you kind of get you focused on
what to do about it rather than going on
about it. Again, we tend not to
talk too much about the past.
We're talking about how things are,
how things are playing out now
because you can't change the past.
What is happening now today
in your relationships,
which maybe we could change.
For example, one of things
we found about people who've,
who've been abused children is not that
they abuse others because they often
they don't.
So a myth sometimes that they do what
they do is they abuse themselves.
So often they attack themselves
rather than attack anybody else.
So that's what you want to work with is
people self harming and self if that's
psychological harming rather
than going into the past.
So I think you hear it then you say,
what do we do about it now?
So you kind of a hopeful where out of it.
It's very sounds.
So,
um,
what do you think the biggest differences
between approaches to clinical
psychology? Um, in the US and the UK are?
That's interesting
because I'm my colleagues,
you know who work in the UK and I
did spend a couple of months in, in,
in uh, in University of Florida
and looking at the system,
the health system there, I'm not
that experienced, but you know what,
I understand one of the big differences
it because we're NHS based clinical
psychology, pine lodge, we,
we tend to have shorter treatments
because of the cost of treatment and we,
so we were very much evidence based, what
is it, the works in the shortest time.
So there's more pressure
to do things more quickly.
Tends to be there for CBT
is the model of choice.
Whereas in the U s is more
psychodynamic therapist,
which is more Freud in
based or relationship based
which take a bit longer.
The evidence is there equally helpful
but they take longer so that's a
difference. We notice that's
the most obvious difference.
Somebody, lots of pants.
Good. I like this.
What do you expect in years to come?
There'll be lots of things in your
redbox associated with social media and
social media pressures,
particularly on adolescents.
Yeah, that's very interesting
cause I think what you are,
one is humans are enormous influence by
people around them and and your close
relationships, your parents, your
friends are very important to you.
Especially for adolescents.
They, there's a huge,
when the press is separation from parents,
we are assumes we need
attachments to others.
Separation process from your parents means
you start to attach to clean the teen
years to your peer group.
If your peer group is a perfect peer
group on social media who all look
fantastic, good parties all
the time and have a great time,
but your not that teaches you,
you're not a very worthwhile person.
So I think yes, I do see that as a
problem and particularly for adolescents,
we know that mental health of young
people today is getting worse and,
and I suspect,
but I don't know well enough
what the evidences of a
social psychologist to come.
We work, you know, the evidence
is on social media stories
really bad.
Um,
and it's a mixture of these social
comparisons that normally if you like,
that's within a group of 25,
uh,
suddenly you've got 700,000 to make
your comparisons with and guess what,
you come out badly.
Um,
and the other thing is that he will behave
worse to each other when they are not
face to face. It's an image. Um, uh,
people do much nastier things to each
other over social media than they would
face to face.
So those two facts naked,
a very dangerous place to be,
even though it's got lots of positives.
I think the programs, there's teaching
people how to use social media because it,
I'm certainly, when I'm, I
don't use Facebook. Whenever
I see anything, I think,
Oh God, these people having
much more fun than I'm having.
But of course it's all myth and story.
I know that. But it's hard when you're,
when you're young. How do you
know that? For sure. So yes,
I think that's one of the
boxes you would put in there,
which is the world around you is much
more likely to be a less comfortable place
to be when you're just a little
you for the oil, a little problems.
So I think that's,
that's certainly true.
And I think that helping people to ways
of dealing with that and understanding
the, of course you put, you spend
hours making the perfect selfie.
Most of us don't look like that most of
the time. So yes. I'm sure that's true.
Eh,
you've mentioned the relationship
between the therapist and therapy.
Uh, how do you deal with, uh,
people that kind of get addicted to your,
to the relationship,
relying more on their therapy then
solving their problems on their own?
Yes, it's ranging issue because one
of the things you're doing when you,
a patient comes and tell with that client,
which have a word you're using,
we use both comes to see you and tells
you they feel like their difficulties.
Um,
my professional job is to listen to the
person and give them my full attention
and understand them.
So I'm giving them a lot of sort
of cues that I'm there for them.
We have to very careful that's not
misunderstood and the relationship because
normally when you sit on your own with
somebody in the room and they're paying
really good attention for an
hour or something, um, that,
that uh, that's very nice,
experienced. We listened to being
valued, especially if the person,
I was very few other places where
they are experienced as valued,
which is why it's very important that we
have a lot of signals and signs around,
which is this is, uh, this is
a professional relationship,
is not a personal relationship.
And there's always that difficulty at
some point where the person may start to,
to wish they had a
personal relationship with.
I've certainly had people want to ask
me out to dinner and people have got,
you know,
t wanted more personal relationship and
that's understandable because you've
being terribly nice to them and you're
listening to them and being there for
them. But again, it's very important
that your vote also very clear.
It's why we often use our professional
titles and we only see people in
consulting rooms. This is not a
social space, this is a workspace.
And all the time you're helping
them to understand that this is a,
this is a way of talking
about your problems. This
isn't solving your problems.
Problems are up there. We're going to
help you get back out there. Again,
this is limited and we also often
talk about time limits. So we'll say,
I'm gonna see you for six sessions. And
we may, in some models we actually say,
well,
you know,
we count down the session so they
know it's going to come to an end.
But it's a very good, and going back
to the, to the question about the USA,
where you work in a more psychodynamic
model forward your model,
that model where you have a longer
term relationship that can be more
problematic and is part of our
training tart to handle that.
And it's understandable why people
can get dependent cause you know,
that happens.
And the other thing is some,
some of some many training also require
you to have experience of therapy.
So you as a therapist can go,
part of your training is to be a patient
and you then discover how easy it is to
idealize the person or to stop rehearsing
what you tell them and tell them that
partly true story and not holds true story
because you're worried about that one.
Yeah. So it sounded good. That
was a good way of handling it.
The clinical body Nice.
Have to make really difficult decisions
about how they allocate resources. Uh,
you know,
we can't afford this particular medicine
for this group of people given there
are so few of you,
I was just interested to know how,
how is it triaged in terms of
who's going to get treatment?
Yes. There's national [inaudible] National
Institute of Clinical Excellence, um,
which will provide a, because that's the
right acronym isn't it? No, mostly yeah,
they,
they provide guidance on what treatments
they do recommend psychological
treatments, um, for a number
of different, uh, uh, call, uh,
conditions, um, based on evidence. And
again, quite rightly better than evidence.
If I have treatment,
I want to know that is it is the right
treatment for my particular condition.
They, they do recommend then for example,
one of these, we known psychosis.
I mentioned psychosis. When people
have major mental health problems,
hallucinations and delusions that the
evidence shows that if you provide
treatment for the individuals
early as possible,
the first episode of psychosis,
which normally happens, uh, in the,
in the late teens, early twenties,
slight different from men and women.
It's a devastate can be a devastating
life course if you, if it fully develops,
if you can get it really early
and get early treatment in,
you can prevent the
condition from developing.
You can help person psychologically,
medically if a team gets in then early.
So if,
if that's a really good news story is
that we don't have longterm patients.
If you can get them quick, you can divert
the psychosis, you can prevent it. Um,
and it's, it's really late, late
teens ish often connected with, well,
Sonos connect with cannabis use,
not always,
and there are no sources of evidence
that the show clear evidence that one of
the components is family tree where you
work with the family to understand how
to deal the young person is they
often still living at home. Uh,
and that is what the Nice,
what the evidence shows we should do.
But there aren't enough people, so a lot
of people don't get the right treatment.
So sadly there are people out there
not getting what we're not nice as they
should get because the
just aren't enough people.
How's the cost of yeah, sure. Yes,
absolutely. Absolutely, absolutely.
All those things are true,
but it's expensive. Nice question. How
we want to spend our money. I mean,
one of the problems I have to say this,
the last few successive governments
have tried and you'll hear on the news
saying, this notion of this
concept is called parity of esteem.
That we esteem our mental health
as much as our physical health.
But it is not the case.
If you have, if you,
if you Sally diagnosed with some kidney
disease or cancer or something, um,
you will get seen pretty quickly and be
seen by the best experts in your area.
Hopefully if you have a mental
health problem like psychosis,
you don't know where they're going to
get treatment because we don't invest as
much in mental, physical health. Um,
that's always been the way because
we stigmatize mental health.
We think there's something wrong with you.
You're to blame somehow
you brought on yourself.
If you have mental
health problem and it's,
it goes quite deep rooted that we use
the word, I use it in casual speech. Oh,
it's psychological. I'll say if I've got
a stomachache, oh, it's psychological.
In other words,
it's not real because it doesn't mean
how to tool because what is psychological
is absolutely real. And we are, we
are, we are physical, mental being,
we're all together. We all, you know,
you can't have a mental health prom
without a physical health problem and vice
versa. But over history we've tended
to put one in box more than the other.
One's good and one's bad.
So mental health hasn't had the
investments in this series. Treatments.
I think that's changing.
I say that is changing.
There is more important
now placed on that.
And certainly going back to the question
of the UK, us, I if he's still here,
gentleness. Oh yes. W is
that we've been much more
nervous to talk about
mental health in the UK.
I think it's changing now, especially
with, with CBT coming more,
having people more access to it to say
you're having therapies now reasonable.
And people talk about that. It
used to be anathema. For example,
in our training when we train people,
I remember my father saying to me
when I was thinking about trainer,
oh that's very interesting. But, um,
you know, it's, it's not, not, uh,
if you want to go into this not working
with very nice people and you'll be so
important that you yourself don't
have any mental health problems.
Now we see it very definitely from that
we see we as trainers and as students
and as practitioners may well have
mental health firms ourselves.
Everybody has mental health problems.
We're not different. We're trying to,
in some ways I might break
my leg or have diabetes.
It doesn't make me a bad doctor.
Likewise,
I might be suffering from
mental health problems. Well,
it's okay to do that is not,
I'm a bad person so we're trying very
much to change the attitudes which are
difficult, but you absolutely right
about that. We should spend more.
But that's a political discussion
which we can have elsewhere.
Thank you. Um, you mentioned that
CBT and online therapies quite new.
Um,
is there any evidence of the moment
whether it's more effective than that face
to face therapy wasn't engineered?
It is. It seems to be with certain,
with certain groups is as effective,
which is quite challenging to all of
us who've been doing it for years. Um,
but what was interesting is, um, yes,
it so does that was effective
and that's a good thing to do,
but it has to be set out right and you
have to get the relationship factors in
there. Right. I mentioned I did the
sleep here program, which was, uh,
which was interesting to do.
But what I found myself doing was I would,
I assume that I was talking to this guy,
you know, I would, I would think, well,
what's he, what's he thinking
about me? Now? Of course it wasn't,
he wasn't thinking it's a program,
but what people do is they
liked it to be a person there.
So I think when we design these things,
well, they can be helpful. One of the,
one of the,
one of the very,
very important things to do is
change how people think about it.
And one of the good things about rolling
out programs is it helps people to
think, to normalize it more. Just quickly.
One point I should make
about the cognitive model I
talked about where you can
think one of the,
one of the most damaging things people
can think about is how abnormal their
thinking is. And if you can normalize
it helped people to know what,
what when one of the things we know
about post traumatic stress disorder, um,
when you've had a traumatic episode,
when something happens,
if a bomb dropped on us, we, it's
gasoline traumatic. We will all have,
but see when we've, hopefully we
survive it. We will have flashbacks,
we will have bad experiences.
If you can understand that that's normal.
Normal people always have bad experiences
after trauma and granted they fade
over the days, the months, your
traumatic experiences that will fade,
then you will get better.
If you think you are odd and unusual
and it's of evidence shows that you are
uniquely week,
uh,
mentally ill because you've had
this trauma is traumatic reaction,
then you won't get better so quickly.
One of the great things about rolling
up large scale is perhaps people will
understand that their reactions are
actually normal. So k to feel trauma.
It's okay to feel bad
and that's rolling out.
Larger scale programs will help people
to see the mental health problems are not
unique. You're not the only one
to feel depressed, sad, angry,
have relationship problems. It's
normal, it's human. And that's, I think,
what large scale programs,
which hopefully organizations such as
yourselves will be helpful to us in
developing.
Thanks very much.